that's all you can eat Bobby doesn't you
like Korean food all the time Wow why
wouldn't I go now you know that we ask
you this there's another little side
fact that I know about just him and I
and what not why we're done with a whole
I think they're gone
yeah you know we can go back I'm just
gonna kind of just throw this a little
back down yeah I think was like five or
six you asked me to audition for another
movie or doing but the the dialogue was
so broken that yeah agent it it was so
thick yes right yeah I just kind of
passed on it and I felt bad because yeah
you know I mean I love him and I want to
work with him again yeah
but just didn't feel it mm-hmm before we
go into that yeah that kind of hurt my
heart a little bit
he did yeah I felt that it did maybe
Heidi you could have texted me let's get
let's go there go now hold on yeah I
obviously wasn't with him he isn't with
me defect 91a
um no but the thing is about the movie
and it wasn't a great movie and it
didn't get to a trickle almost did it
didn't include thousand reruns all time
it was called the hungover games and so
it was kind of almost like we're doing
with sarin talk it was like the guys
from the hungover yeah I know what it
was woke up yeah yeah no and they were
in what's that place and yeah in The
Hunger Games yeah well they woke up
there yeah anyway so was like a parody
your character was the Ken John
character was his name yeah yeah
hangover yeah so you know mr. chow yeah
but it was a super over-the-top bad on
purpose I was like an all
so it was like why is he going over the
top yeah you understand who got it that
fan is that a bad word here dad sweetest
guys we just got in the world sweetest
guy in the whole world
friendliest guy he's so friendly yeah he
won the thing yeah yeah he won and he
was the nicest guy ever talk to him in a
while yeah I have no turn from white to
pan down mug he went back farther in the
closet yeah he came in he read a bunch
of times
I love them so much
isn't that we talk about him a lot yes
and we love them on the show you'll
never do it wow there's some kind of
thing no there's no thing there's no
it's really he'll never do it I'm doing
it does that matter okay I'm gonna have
Jordan do it all right all right there's
obviously a thing it just stops us I
just want to say that I'm gonna say this
okay I'll shut up there I'm just gonna
say this and I'm not making fun of
anybody I'm not this is not I'm watching
what I'm saying and when I [ __ ] took
down truTV I'm [ __ ]
no you're not I like okay this is that
you and Jordan right mm-hmm you guys are
were and they are in movies and [ __ ]
mm-hmm that's it I took I got that my
point taken yeah yeah history I don't
know
[Music]